[Musique]
madame monsieur bonjour et bienvenue en
direct sur le plateau de dimanche en
politique en bourgogne et sur notre page
facebook l'élection présidentielle se
rapproche à grands pas il ne reste que
trois semaines avant le premier tour
nous vous proposons un dernier débat
avec nos 5 invitez d'amis raconte un
bonjour conseiller régional front
national soutiennent marine le pen
bonjour jean yves caullet député ps de
l'yonne soutien des manuels macron
bonjour patricia marque pour la france a
soumises soutien de jean-luc mélenchon
bonjour claire rocher porte parole de
lutte ouvrière et soutien de nathalie
arthaud et charles-henri gallois en
charge des questions économiques à l'upm
l'union populaire républicaine soutien
de françois asselineau
je précise que nous avions lancé une
invitation à l'équipe de campagne de
jean lassalle mais nous n'avons obtenu
aucune réponse alors jamais une campagne
n'aura été aussi chaotique cette semaine
encore on aura vu entre autres la mise
en examen de pénélope fillon après celle
de son mari des révélations du monde qui
accable marine le pen sur le financement
de son parti
manuel valls qui rompt avec son
engagement de soutenir le vainqueur de
la première et qui annonce son soutien à
emmanuel macron une percée spectaculaire
de jean luc mélenchon dans les sondages
une remise en cause du dernier débat sur
france 2 etc etc
jean yves caullet même la première
question sera pour vous emmanuel macron
a rendu visite à christian estrosi le
patron d'une des républiques and paca
les sympathisants ps sont complètement
déboussolés en ce moment est-ce que du
coup vous êtes toujours vous socialiste
malgré votre engagement
écoutez je suis avec mes convictions je
les apporte pour les conjuguée avec
celle d'autres dans un projet qui me
paraît novateur et intéressant pour mon
pays je trouve un peu extraordinaire
d'ailleurs qu'une visite
une rencontre dont le contenu d'ailleurs
n'intéresse absolument pas les
commentateurs fasse autant de taux et
volumes moi je connais pas une famille
une équipe une entreprise où des gens
qui sont pas d'accord entre eux ne se
parlent pas ne se rencontrent pas donc
voilà il a rencontré christian estrosi
contre elle moi j'ai mes convictions mes
convictions n'ont pas changé la
solidarité nécessaire à l'émancipation
et vous avez les mêmes idées que votre
ancien adversaire monsieur lemoine dans
votre département des sénateurs je n'ai
pas les mêmes idées là mais surtout mais
si le projet que porte et même accro
rassemble des gens qui viennent
d'horizons différentes et si nous sommes
d'accord pour le mettre en oeuvre nous
agirons de concert alors damien quentin
le monde publié jeudi
des documents qui tendent à prouver
l'existence d'emplois fictifs au
parlement européen pour contribuer au
financement du fn est ce que ça vous
laisse de marbre toutes ces révélations
on a bien compris que le système tremble
approche des élections et veut tout
faire pour discréditer marine le pen qui
est en tête dans quasiment tous les
sondages avec les soi-disant emplois
fictifs au parlement européen
le monde a aussi réveillé des mails mais
des malheurs qui ne prouve rien il n'y a
aucun contenu et on voit aujourd'hui que
notamment france télévisions madame
ernotte fait campagne contre marine le
pen avec d envoyé spécial
un téléfilm contre le front national on
révèle des mails mais on ne parle pas de
là on ne parle pas du fond ne parle pas
du programme amal révision et à des
émissions sur le fond où on a bien vu
sur sur france 2 avec monsieur pujadas
qui je pense n'a pas été partial lors de
son interview pour continuer ce tour
d'horizon de l'actualité
madame marque il ya une percée de jean
luc mélenchon a dans les sondages ces
derniers temps et puis aussi sa fin de
non recevoir à une union avec benoît
hamon or selon les sondages si on
additionne les deux scores des deux
candidats vous seriez en capacité d'être
quasiment score de madame le pen de
monsieur macro qu'est ce qui fait que
vous vous unissez pas vous préféré
perdre c'est à dire pour l'instant étant
donnée la loi électorale qui ne permet
pas un candidat s'est désisté son peine
de perdre le remboursement des élections
donc ont de toute façon c'est trop tard
pour se désister
alors on aurait bien voulu que monsieur
hamon nous rejoignent avant gains avant
on l'aurait accueilli les bras les bras
ouverts
certainement bon il ne l'a pas fait mais
maintenant c'est trop tard mais ça donne
un peu l'impression vous pourrez vous
préféré perdre plutôt que de gagner non
pas du tout enfin de nous espérons
d'ailleurs au deuxième tour un deuxième
tour est d'ailleurs la progression de
jean luc mélenchon le montre que ce
n'est pas quelque chose d'impossible
les rochers nathalie arthaud a redit
c'était dimanche dernier lors de son
grand meeting à aubervilliers qu'elle
n'était pas candidate pour être
présidente de la république alors est-ce
qu'elle ne se trompe pas de combat
finalement en se présentant quand même
écouter non bien sûr que non
ben moi je voudrais revenir sur les
alliances et les calculs des uns et des
autres bon quand on est un électeur des
classes populaires qu'on voit tous
annoncé leur calcul c'est leur petit
monde et non seulement on y étrangers
mais en plus les électeurs des classes
populaires ça les dégoûte profondément
cette arrivisme ce carriérisme enfin est
justement 1 nathalie arthaud elle l est
pas du tout candidate dans cette optique
là elle calcule pas selon les postes
qu'elle peut avoir
nous on est là pour dénoncer derrière
ces micmacs les vrais responsables ceux
qui tirent vraiment les ficelles vous
savez il ya il ya 21 milliardaire en
france qui gagne autant que plus de 20
millions de femmes et d'hommes ces gens
avec leurs capitaux avec leur fortune
accumulée
ça leur donne un pouvoir extraordinaire
ils font leur fortune sur notre travail
sur le travail de millions d'hommes et
on sait très bien que quel que soit le
président élu
au final il se mettra au service de ces
gens donc justement non nathalie arthaud
elle se présente pour dénoncer ses
responsables là et pour permettre aux
travailleurs qui le souhaitent de le
faire avec elle françois asselineau a
fait son premier meeting monsieur
gallois c'était samedi dernier à paris
lors d'un autre prévue en début de
semaine il est plus présent dans les
médias et il est toujours entre 0 et 0
5% dans les sondages c'est une
candidature utile
j'ai une candidature utile et vous
verrez que notre score sera bien plus
important que ce que disent les pseudos
son âge si vous avez d'autres sondages
notamment sur internet qui porte sur des
échantillons bien plus grand et à chaque
fois on fait des scores assez
extraordinaire série pas fondées gros
échantillons beaucoup moins quand même
mais pour revenir effectivement cette
élection non seulement à faire un gros
score parce que vous parliez des
affaires ou même des ralliements de
monsieur macron alors ça va de robert
hue allainmat
là en plus monsieur macron vous pas
oublier quand même que il a été quatre
ans gouvernement hollande finalement
c'est exactement la continuité c'est pas
le renouvellement c'est françois
hollande avec du maquillage un gros
régime
on va pas se leurrer et après quand on
voit les têtes voilà c'est pas des têtes
nouvelles la seule tête nouvelle à cette
élection et qui propose un projet
différent et qui va au fond des choses
et j'espère qu'on pourra le faire
aujourd'hui c'est évidemment françois
séguineau le candidat du frac site
alors justement aller au fond des choses
et parler de l'europe si vous le voulez
bien c'est un thème qui vous tient à
coeur d'ailleurs ce gallois la plupart
des candidats ont passé leur grand oral
cette semaine devant les agriculteurs
les chefs d'entreprises risquent donc ce
thème commun de l'europe au centre des
questions
charles-henri gallois je vais commencer
par vous c'est votre candidat qui défend
le plus la sortie de l'europe est
également
je dirais que c'est même le sol puisque
comme j'essaie le cordier a du fric si
en fait pour nous il ya un candidat du
frac si françois cellino et dix
candidats qui propose une autre europe
mais cette histoire d'autres europe il
faut que vos téléspectateurs se rendent
compte ça fait 60 ans qu'on nous vend la
même salade et pourquoi c'est impossible
d'avoir une autre europe pour changer
les traités
c'est l'article 48 du traité sur l'union
européenne
il faut l'unanimité des états membres
qui ont des intérêts nationaux
complètement divergents sur à peu près
tous les sujets donc quand vous dites
comme tous les autres candidats et c'est
bien gentil je vais faire une autre
europe c'est mentir aux français on le
sait tout le monde le sait et donc nous
on propose le fric site mais c'est pas
seulement un projet négatif c'est un
projet très positif puisque en faisant
le fric site vous pouvez récupérer des
sommes colossales notamment la
contribution nette de la france à
l'union européenne c'est de l'ordre de 9
milliards par an tout ce qui est de
l'ordre des cofinancements ces cinq
milliards par an et aussi toute la
fraude et l'évasion fiscale et 11
puisque ça c'est entre 60 et 80 milliard
par an faut savoir que la seule façon de
lutter contre la fraude évasion fiscale
c'est le contrôle des mouvements de
capitaux qui est interdit par les
traités européens et sans peut récupérer
ses 60 80 on peut récupérer au moins 20
milliards d'euros
donc le fric site est évidemment la
solution pour la france et pas seulement
économique évidemment pour reprend
notre destin est retrouvé en démocratie
que les rochers dans le programme de
votre candidate elle veut placer elle
veut mettre en place par dont les états
unis socialistes d'europe
ça veut dire quoi concrètement écoutez
si on parle en parlant d'europe de ces
institutions européennes de la
bourgeoisie elles ont été enfin faite
par la bourgeoisie européenne et pour
elle c'est des institutions qui lui ont
servi à faire un marché commun à faire
en sorte que ces marchandises puissent
circuler de pouvoir implanter ses usines
dans les pays où les travailleurs sont
encore un peu plus écrasés voilà ces
institutions elles ont servi à ça et on
sent cela nous on les combat bien sûr
par contre moi je
je me sens je suis européenne on peut
aller d'un bout à l'autre du continent
en quatre ou cinq heures on va pas
mettre des frontières tous les 200 km on
va pas cesser à l'heure des grandes
nations de la chine de la russie des
états unis on va pas tour découpé en
confettis c'est anachronique
voilà et donc bah oui effectivement nous
on est pour les états socialiste les
états unis socialistes d'europe des
travailleurs mais effectivement c'est
pas cette europe là est par contre on
est vraiment pour la suppression des
frontières
damien quentin alors vous marine le pen
propose un référendum dès son arrivée au
pouvoir si elle y arrive mais on ne
comprend pas masqué de complètement
sortir de l'europe ce que voisine le
mans ne prétend pas messieurs gallois ou
est ce qu elle veut simplement sortir de
l'euro est ce qu'elle veut renégocier ce
qu'elle veut faire une place
alors le référendum n'aura pas lieu
directement comme comme vous le dites
six mois après l'élection présidentielle
après avoir négocié avec négocier avec
certains certains accords avec d'autres
pays et si on n'obtient pas d'accord et
effectivement on se remettra au peuple
avec un référendum pour sortir de
l'union européenne parce qu'on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui cette europe 1
tambours de l'histoire c'est une europe
en faillite qui est porté uniquement par
dame par madame merkel avec un
entêtement incompréhensible et marine le
pen veux rendre à la france sa
souveraineté nationale avec une europe
des nations indépendantes et libres
la marque vous avez appelé le même
programme que le front national à propos
de l'europe
exactement en fait il est certain que
l'europe actuelle n'est pas celle que
nous voulons une europe des financiers
ne convient pas ce que nous voulons
c'est renégocier les traités avec comme
but une organisation sociale une
harmonisation fiscale pour mettre fin au
dumping social et arrêter les
déréglementations des services publics
auquel nous sommes très attachés en aura
l'occasion de reparler peut-être là la
fonction publique et nous souhaitons une
modification du rôle de la bce qui pour
l'instant le prêt de co banque et refuse
de traiter directement aux états mais
quand même jean luc mélenchon dit qu'il
veut sortir des traités européens
il veut négocier il veut renégocier les
traités ce qui est impossible
ça c'est vous qui le dites jacques
pollet alors finalement dans cette
assemblée
vous serez le seul à défendre l'europe
actuelle écoutez moi je défends l'europe
parce qu'elle nous apporter la paix sur
incontinence d'un petit détail je sais
bien enfin quand même le rappeler
qu'elle nous permet de nous structurer
dans un monde où il n'est pas comment
dire inutile de savoir défendre des
intérêts communs fasse effectivement à
des puissances émergentes comme l'inde
la chine ou la russie de monsieur
poutine ou les états unis de monsieur
trump et je pense qu'on est plus fort
sur le continent européen en étant
ensemble qu'en étant chacun dans son
coin pense aussi que il faut prendre la
main que les citoyens prennent la main
dans les institutions
donc ils ont la disposition sur le
parlement je pense que notre pays
s'affaiblit quand il envoie parlement
européen des gens qui sont contre
l'europe parce que la voix de la france
évidemment à peine à s'y trouver un
chemin je pense qu'il faut travailler
sur la convergence fiscale et sociale
c'est une nécessité
je pense aussi que les pays moins
développés deux autres qui ont rejoint
l'europe profite c'est vrai de d'un élan
économique et quand même qui bénéficie
aussi à leur population
je pense que c'est ensemble qu'on peut
investir pour l'avenir et relever les
défis technologiques numériques
écologique et énergétique
au moment où tous vos adversaires et
notamment la droite dit que emmanuel
macron c'est l'héritier de françois
hollande
est ce qu'il y aura pas une espèce de
continuité sur ce point là au moins de
la politique actuelle il ya une
continuité à ce moment là s'ils
voulaient depuis la construction
européenne et jean monnet le fait est
pour l'europe ne signifie pas une
continuité politique d'ailleurs cette
continuité politique c'est le dernier
avatar de la campagne de monsieur fillon
et des adversaires des manuels macron
qui savent pas trop quoi dire sur un
programme structuré conçu construit et
cohérent et qu'ils essayent de broder
autour de différentes prises de position
ça ne change rien à la chose l'europe
sera plus forte dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui que les états pris
individuellement les agriculteurs savent
très bien que sans la pac
ils sont ruinés que l'idée farfelue les
l'idée farfelue d'une politique
européenne française que défendre marine
le pen est une catastrophe et que nous
achetons et nous vendons des produits
d'excellence français nous achetons les
produits d'excellence de nos partenaires
et que si nous fermons les frontières je
pense que les gens de chablis auront du
mal à vendre leurs vins à l'extérieur et
ils savent très bien ce qu'il en est je
pense que monsieur joue sur les peurs
évidemment puisque la suisse par young
menée par l'union européenne et ex porte
est ouverte sur le monde et comme la
norvège comme une islande donc c'est
vraiment ça des arguments de la peur
tétanisant et qui ne sont pas au niveau
du saumon mais bien et l'europe c'est la
paix c'est évidemment un mensonge
puisque ce n'est pas lady la directive
sur le beurre de cacahuète qui a fait la
paix c'est la dissuasion nucléaire où il
y avait d'un côté l'otan et de l'autre
le pacte de varsovie
donc ce vieux message un petit peu de
propagande qu'on entend mais là encore
pas une vérité je suis désolé de le
rappeler à la fonction publique elle est
très présente dans cette campagne avec
notamment les discours de françois
fillon ou d'emmanuel macron sur la
baisse du nombre d'agents nécessaire
alors les syndicats de la fonction
publique disent qu'ils en ont un peu
assez d'être considéré comme un coût 1
pour leur société alors que les services
publics sont largement plébiscité par
dont parlait français qu'est ce que vous
leur dites aujourd'hui
le fonctionnaire qui représente quand
même 10 % du corps électoral
messieurs tout et les trois fonctions
publiques hospitalière fonctions d'état
et fonction publique territoriale sont
des outils de l'action publique
ils sont en france de qualité et sans
erreurs c'est certain mais il faut
privilégier les secteurs d'activité au
plus proche des besoins des français la
santé la sécurité la justice
c'est ce que propose emmanuel macron
mais il faut aussi bien constater que
depuis la décentralisation l'état
central n'a pas réussi à céder
réellement l'ensemble des compétences
aux collectivités locales qu'ils gardent
la main dans un certain nombre de
secteurs qui lient à des doublons qui
sont pesant que un certain nombre de
compétences et de talents dans la
fonction publique notamment d'état que
je connais bien sont employés à gérer
des procédures voire à les créer qui ne
sont pas forcément des plus simples et
plus faciles donc je pense qu'il est
possible effectivement d'alléger un
petit peu l'appareil de l'état dans les
secteurs non priorité si je comprends
bien c'est à la tête de l'état s'est pas
seul car je pense qu'il y as et
d'ailleurs ça a été dit très clairement
la fonction publique hospitalière n'est
pas en cause les fonctions régaliennes
de sécurité de défense non plus et régis
non plus nous avons effectivement au
niveau de l'administration de l'état et
en particulièrement au niveau central
avec la simplification de nos procédures
une meilleure des concentrations une
décentralisation plus affirmée jusqu'au
bout y compris en matière justement de
fonction publique je pense qu'on a les
moyens effectivement d'alléger sans
perturber l'efficacité j'adresse à marcq
je voudrais faire le lien avec ceux dont
on vient de parler l'europe a les
traités européens nous impose
l'austérité budgétaire et donc la
destruction des services la destruction
des services publics et ceci est
incompatible avec notre programme l
avenir en commun dans lequel nous
mettons il ya 83 propositions et dans
lequel nous mettons en évidence les
éléments la politique sociale notamment
en matière d'éducation en matière des
services publics nous voulons la
sécurité la scolarité obligatoire pour
les élèves de 3 à 18 ans le recrutement
de 60000 enseignants
en ce qui concerne l'accès aux soins
vidal je défends aussi l'éducation et
l'accès aux soins nous voulons un
service de médecins généralistes
fonctionnaires d'état qui seront qui
exerceront en milieu rural pour lutter
contre les déserts les déserts médicaux
et nous voulons prendre en compte aussi
un point très important de notre
programme
les personnes en situation de handicap
avec des mesures fortes comme augmenter
l'allocation aux adultes handicapés au
niveau du smic
ce compte a pas de suppressions
d'effectifs pour marine le pen ont au
contraire notamment on va dire pour les
forces de l'ordre
une embauche de 15 mille policiers et
gendarmes afin de les recentrer sur
leurs activités principales la sécurité
des français et les décharges et aussi
des des tâches administratives qui sont
assez lourdes et qui les empêche de
faire correctement leurs fonctions
et n'en déplaise à plusieurs de mes
camarades autour de la table un
recrutement de 6000 agents 6000 agents
de douanes
parce que nous voulons rétablir les
frontières et les contrôler les
frontières internes
oui tout à fait et vous avez également
de votre programme la suppression des
conseils régionaux c'est toujours c'est
toujours le cas vous qui êtes conseiller
régional c'est tout le c'est toujours le
cas nous voulons nous voulons supprimer
adoration conseil régional ce qui va
entraver l'action collective c'est pas
vraiment ce qu'on fait au conseil
régional monsieur votre femme qui siège
au conseil régional pour provenant par
les courants de vos méthodes si elle a
le temps parce que comme elle est aussi
assistante parlementaire à temps plein
je sais pas si elle avait un métier oui
mais voilà un métier aussi à temps plein
+ dj lord issa se voir si j'y arrive
j'arrive n'y a pas de problème j'arrive
à concilier deux et je ne dis pas que à
4000 euros je gagne moins que ce que je
gagnais avant parce que nous défendrons
front national nous défendons le peuple
est pas là la banque rothschild est très
ambitieux malgré les compétences aussi
de tous quand ils ont donc eu des cas là
vous vous êtes dans la fonction publique
hospitalière en plus oui bien sûr je la
défends et cessons d embauche qu'il faut
quand on les écoute tout cela c'est
comme si la fonction publique c'était un
coût insupportable que
des toits des offres privilégiées à
écouter c'est ce qu'on sait ce qu'on
entend laisser ce qu'on a envie mais ce
qu'on a envie nous à l'hôpital donc moi
même je suis infirmière on nous rappelle
à 23h à 2h à 4h du matin pour venir
travailler à 6h30
parce qu' il manque quelqu'un on est en
sous-effectif en permanence on entasse
trois patients dans une chambre pour 2
alors qu'il n'ya même pas il ya que deux
prises d'oxygène ya que deux sonnette
pour appeler au secours
en cardiologie 1 et donc ça c'est ce
qu'on vit ça c'est ce que j la fonction
publique et donc moi je fais je suis je
suis révolté parce que c'est en plus ça
n'est pas une question de manque
d'argent je tiens à le dire
on nous raconte que ya plus d'argent ou
que l'europe dit ceci ou etc
mais tout ça cdc pour faire diversion la
vraie réalité en fait c'est que les
hôpitaux ils ont été contraints de
s'endetter ils sont été mis sous la
dépendance des banques et maintenant
c'est elle qui dictent leur politique et
moi je pense qu'il va falloir qu'on se
battre collectivement contre cette
évolution
que dit françois ce qui est bon à ce
propos alors françois c'est inouï
rappelle l'article 5 de la constitution
qui est que le président la république
est garant de l'indépendance nationale
mais aussi de l'intégrité du territoire
et quand on parle des fonctionnaires est
évidemment là je pense aux zones rurales
et je pense aussi à nos compatriotes
d'outre-mer
il ya évidemment des carences énormes à
ce niveau-là et madame à ma droite a
clairement raison est évidemment le
cadre des traités européens qui impose
cela non seulement d'un point de vue
osterrieth air mais aussi l'article 106
du traité sur le fonctionnement de
l'union européenne qui stipule que
quasiment l'intégralité des services
publics doivent être privatisée et mis
en concurrence donc on peut pas faire
des grands discours et c'est à dire
qu'on veut sauver la fonction publique
et dans le même temps dire qu'on va
rester dans l'union européenne et nous
justement c'est un des points d'ailleurs
pour lequel nous voulons le fric site
c'est pour sauver nos services publics
que ce soit comme je l'aï dit en zone
rurale ou notamment dans l'outre-mer qui
est honteusement délaissé alors que
normalement c'est un des rôles majeurs
du président de la république
on l'a vu avec la guyane cette semaine
noah est à peine cinq minutes
je voudrais faire référence à aura 33
qui vous a laissé cette question sur
notre site internet y at il un
politicien capable de nous faire sortir
de l' angoisse permanente qui pèse sur
la france
voilà en guise de conclusion dites nous
pourquoi pourquoi on aurait raison de
voter pour votre candidat
ce compte a par exemple j'invite tous
les patriotes de france à rejoindre
marine le pen ainsi qu'aux causes
indécis à lire les 144 engagements de
campagne
parce qu'aujourd'hui le choix du 23
avril est due et du 7 mai est un choix
de civilisation et ils ans il engagera
aussi nos enfants sur le pour plus tard
donc il faut vraiment mettre à la tête
de l'état à la tête du pays une femme
qui pourra s'opposer aux puissances
financières à bruxelles et qui donnera à
la france sa liberté qui écoutera de
nouveau le peuple parce que je pense
qu'aujourd'hui malheureusement nos
policiers et nos politiciens n'écoute
pas le peuple
n'écoute plus personne et ne font que
pour leurs intérêts madame rocher
pourquoi vos traitements pour l'europe
comme pour la france
le problème c'est la domination des
capitalistes et de la finance et les
travailleurs ils seront pas protégés de
sa part des frontières ils seront pas
protégés de sa non plus par un président
de la république
ils seront protégés que quand ils se
battront et c'est fondamental que dans
cette campagne là les travailleurs comme
mois il puisse faire entendre leur
intérêt réel le droit d'avoir une vie
décente et pour ça ne pas avoir de
salaire inférieur à 1800 euros
le droit de ne pas dépendre des
desiderata des patrons et l'interdiction
des licenciements le droit de ne pas se
retrouver dans la misère pour des
calculs financiers et ça ils peuvent
l'affirmer en votant pour nathalie
arthaud à l'élection présidentielle
merci ce gallois quel intérêt dans cette
élection
quand vous votez pour monsieur
asselineau voté non seulement pour des
avantages considérables sur le plan
économique au niveau du fric si
d'ailleurs des avantages on n'a pas eu
le temps d'en parler
énorme d'un point de vue de la sortie de
l'euro donc j'ai envie de dire à nos
compatriotes de ne pas avoir peur et de
vote
pour le candidat du fric si du sang pour
retrouver notre démocratie tout
simplement notre choix et notre liberté
les français se rendent compte qu'ils
votent à gauche ou qui votent à droite
ils ont exactement la même politique qui
est celle qui est décidée par une entité
supranationale non élu et non légitime
donc j'invite tous les français tout
simplement à sauver notre pays a sauvé
ce qu'est la france pour vos enfants
pour vos petits enfants et pour l'avenir
de votre pays reconnaît pourquoi voter
pour emmanuel macron écoutez je pense
que c'est le candidat dans le projet
répond le mieux à la question vous avez
évoqué d'un internaute ou demandant qui
est ce qui va nous faire sortir de cette
angoisse permanente
je pense que le programme d' emmanuel
macron propose justement à chacun de
retrouver une part des clés de l'avenir
collectif d'être des acteurs de l'avenir
de la france
c'est un projet émancipateur c'est un
projet protecteur une juste protection
une libération des énergies qui fasse
des françaises et des français des
acteurs de leur avenir de nos
territoires des parties de la république
qui soit porté là-aussi vers le projet
de relever les défis de demain de faire
une france forte dans une europe ouverte
et de faire une france où on est fier
d'être français
parce qu'on retrouve le chemin de
l'avenir on en est responsable on est
libre et on est solidaire madame
patricia marc pour jean luc mélenchon
alors pourquoi voter pour l'enfant parce
qu'avec jean luc mélenchon peut tourner
la page de l'austérité et le point phare
de son programme c'est un nouveau
partage des richesses
le smic à 3026 à 1326 euros nets
c'est mélenchon l'attention de retraite
au niveau du smic c'est mélenchon la
retraite à 60 ans les 40 annuités c'est
mélenchon le remboursement à 100% des
soins de santé
c'est méchant une allocation de 800
euros pour les étudiants de 18 à 25 ans
et mêlant chant la france est un pays
riche on le voit avec les dividentes de
qui ont été versés en 2016
aux actionnaires près de 7 57 milliards
d'euros
donc c'est pour cela qu'il faut voter
jean luc mélenchon pour rétablir les
équilibres un petit mot tout c'est
encore jouable
il ya encore un suspense dans cette
présidentielle parce qu'on voit que les
français ne sont encore très bas sont
encore très indécis
quelqu'un peut dire à mon avis forcément
il ya des années 70 se comprendre qu'il
y ait des indécis parce que d'un côté
d'un côté les socialistes ont trahi en
trail la gauche et puis de l'autre côté
vous avez la droite qui écoeuré par les
affaires et ceci dit j'ai envie que dans
leurs champs je tiens à le dire parce
que je tiens à le dire jean luc
mélenchon n'est pas n'est pas français
en détresse et à faire il n'est pas
convoqué par les juges
et donc c'est la personne pour laquelle
il faudrait qu'on me fasse les no way
que l'abstention s'annonce énorme et je
pense que françois co2 par son projet
rassembleur au delà du clivage gauche
droite est la seule nouvelle tête jean 6
à cette élection peut rassembler tous
ces abstentionnistes sur sa candidature
se canta ça vous inquiète cette
abstention au contraire ça peut vous
favorisez non l'abstention nous
inquiètent bien sûr aujourd'hui on peut
pas se réjouir de kissi des millions de
personnes ne vont pas ne vont pas aux
urnes
et on sait que l'on dispose d'un gros
gros réservoir de voix c'est celle ci
les abstentionnistes on va les mobiliser
pour être en tête le soir du premier
tour et remporté l'élection de sept mais
même objectif rien n'est jamais gagné
une campagne se termine quand elle est
finie ça n'est pas le cas nous avons à
convaincre emmanuel macron porte un
projet il ouvre une nouvelle porte pour
l'avenir et ça me paraît de nature à
faire venir aux urnes
tous les concitoyens un crochet je
m'adresse aux travailleurs pour leur
dire que le seul enjeu pour eux c'est de
faire entendre leur camp et leur intérêt
est de prendre conscience qu'ils ont les
moyens de se défendre parce qu'on va
être attaqué et donc on se présente pour
défendre un programme de combat merci
merci à tous d'avoir accepté notre
invitation voudrait revoir ce débat bien
sûr sur notre page facebook ou sur notre
site internet tout de suite place à
l'info régionale avec les requins avec
ce terrible accident qui a eu lieu cette
nuit en saône et loire dimanche champ
politique continue juste après francis
letellier reçoit nadine morano et
thierry mandon bon appétit et bon
dimanche à tous
[Musique]
mercredi sur france 3